most ridiculous anime hairstyles and
what that says about the character
[Laughter]
I mean uh Yu-Gi-Oh yeah I think every
year every every character from you here
every character in you just like just
like well not even not even joking just
like just Yugi like like first of all I
feel bad for cosplayers because they
first they have to figure out what the
[__] is going on with you he's here and
second of all I'm just imagining like
does he style that [__] every morning
like how long must that take I think you
says commitment commitment it is
commitment we know about you yeah I
think Yu-Gi-Oh has ruined every card
game anime character design because
sometimes you just look at a card game
like anime character and you're like
this is a rip-off Yu-gi-oh character
yeah you can always tell when an anime
is about card games when they have the
craziest craziest ass [__] hair that
would not exist in real life even by
anime standards man it begins with Hugo
it's not even the hair either it's just
like just character designs in general
like all harsh edges all very like
pointy yeah all different colors it
can't just be one color it has to be
like multiple colors like streaks or
some [__] I was sick though because it
was like the only only thing that was
caution is always rounded soft and
colorful and here was this show that was
[__] crazy and every character had
the most absurd hair and you're just
like what the [__] yeah yeah because I
remember even like the most normal
character hairstyle wise in Yu-Gi-Oh is
probably maybe like I don't know Pegasus
right but even then it's like his
[__] character design is so [__]
whacked out and he's so batshit insane
as a personality where it's like he
plays a pretty normal hairstyle
obviously it's just it's just very very
long and you know straight and white but
like you know but everything else about
him is just like whoa all right chill
what does the hairstyle say about the
characters though that's what I'm in
true they're the main character
the amount of times you're sitting in a
classroom when you're like I spot the
main character I can tell who the main
character is let me let me let me just
look around and see who has the craziest
ass [__] his ass it's just it's just
a matter of like I think so many
characters so many like series that have
so many characters especially they're
the only way you can differentiate is
being like what color have we used on
the color wheel yet let's make it that
color is there any anime where the
character changes their hairstyle
um
I'm sure there is uh yeah Dragon Ball Z
shut the [__] up Joey
Scoot and Super Saiyan 3 Goku is dude
it's like a completely different
character who the [__] is this yeah Goku
literally has a lion mane yeah that's
super saiyan 3. do you know do you know
what's ruin Super Saiyan 3 for me yeah
he has no eyebrows and once I noticed
that I could have not noticed that oh my
God he doesn't they replace his eyebrows
with muscles his eyebrows just like go
up into his hair like Lego Super Saiyan
3 Goku and they have replaced his
eyebrows with muscles and once I've
noticed that I cannot not notice that
it's probably just Toriano being like
man I'm spending too much time on the
hair I just forgot the eyebrows so I
guess I'm still using some of these
characters I've never seen there's a
gravel dare bloice from gosic has this
insane like torpedo hair oh yes yeah I
love him he's [__] sick and then
obviously Charles zebra Tanya that's not
like a bit that's his actual hair
like an accessory that's his hair oh my
God so he's not wearing a wig like a
judge yeah yeah and uh I guess uh Ken
Patchy from Bleach yeah yeah not a lot
of Bleach characters have some wild hair
yeah
from ping pong the animation I don't
even know this character I forgot about
that
um uh oh yeah oh yeah tender from Romer
half as well he's got he's all crazy
it's ragio from killer kill as well
she's literally just rainbows in her
hair at some point oh bro I forgot about
her yeah every character in cheeky
uh yeah JoJo's weird because JoJo's hair
is just half hat half hat yeah like it's
like a weird that he's the hat is the
head the Hat doesn't do anything in his
hair uh it's very odd uh there's also
obviously
um Death the Kid from oh yeah oh yeah
yeah
that's good that that actually does tell
us a little bit about the character yeah
yeah that he loves symmetry except it's
not symmetry except it's not something
it's the one thing that's not
symmetrical yeah I I love it when it
whenever whenever you want to make a
character see more mature just flatten
their hair like get the spikes out
flatten the hair they are an adult now
that's what you did
honestly in real life as well calm down
settle down go to life
that's the Trope that I I can actually
get that applies to real life yeah damn
or just have them like grow their hair
out and if they're if they're if they're
meant to be the good looking main
character they'll have their eyes
slightly covered and it'll be oh yeah
yeah there's always the always the
streak here if they're a little bit of
the quirky character give them the ahog
here yeah if they're a happy girl lucky
character they'll have like the quiff
s I'm ready
Target that just runs in runs and
everything
why why is it we're going back to tropes
now but why is it the Trope whenever you
want to make an anime character look
sassy just get just give them like the
the [__] slit eyes man you know the
eyes that never open and I'm just like
what well because it makes you be like
what are you actually looking at what
are you hiding what are you hiding why
are you opening those eyes man what the
[__] I think you guys thank God you guys
are saying that if I said that that's
I'm so racist why did these Asian people
opening their eyes what's happening with
them yeah I'm just I look at Brock and
I'm like
what do you want to [__] uh TSA and
immigration like what are you up to but
then but then the opposite can be said
right of like when you do it finally see
his eyes you're like oh [__] shit's
about to go down when they open their
eyes you're like oh [__] it's going down
that's when they reveal their grand plan
they read business when you can see
their pupils yeah
[Music]
what's a hairstyle that you looked at in
an anime and you're like that could
probably work in real life as ridiculous
as Sasuke because I did it yeah that's
true yeah
like I could as as weird as it is I
could imagine someone pulling off like a
Death the Kid haircut
uh because it's like it's just yeah I
think they have you know it's just like
white streaks here right that go around
like it will look weird as [__] but it's
probably the most realistic with the
half hair colors look pretty cool in
real life actually oh like the the half
off yeah
I've seen people do that
um what uh what colors do you think what
anime colors you think work in real life
definitely not pink like the ones that
happen in anime that do just make fun
well I guess it works for me it's just
cool down you know what you know what
doesn't work ever blue like light blue
like it never I'm like green green looks
like ass in real life in calling out
Jacksepticeye and cranky Place
good they could take it like the big
boys what do you think Jack stop doing
it because he got lazy yeah that too
yeah it's a lot of it's a lot of
management does anyone do it aside from
streamers and you yeah
I don't even want to know how much how
much die ninja head to use it just
doesn't look good in real life yeah does
orange look good [__] no because I'm
just thinking about Ichigo and I'm like
damn Ichigo got drip but I'm like
Georgia does don't no Ginger no Ginger
though okay okay yeah Ginger Ginger
looks fine but like this
Ginger looks great but like if you're
Japanese then it's a different story oh
yeah it does very I think Gigi hair on a
Japanese person is a little like whoa
you know yeah yeah I guess it does
depend on uh skin complex exactly
exactly yeah I I'm sticking to my hair
color like this I want to see someone
pull off gone's haircut from Hunter
Hunter when he's like an adult
what the [__] I don't know there's
someone's done it online have they yeah
someone's done it yes I've seen someone
do I've seen someone do it oh my God
I've seen like somebody do it it's
really [__] sick okay now I want to
see someone pull off the Homer Simpson
haircut that's what I want to see in
real life I'm getting that yeah
I want to see that in real life to be
like all right it looks it looks fine on
Homer but how does it look on an actual
person
Wild on their actual person
oh my God I wanna like I feel like one
like
one Steeda just always does character
designs well including the haircuts and
everything Studio trigger I don't know
why yeah something about Studio trigger
character designs they always [__]
stand out every single time and
sometimes it always takes like one
[__] streak of color and you're like
okay that's Riku from kill or kill I
know now yeah her stuff's great yeah it
does it does reflect her energy as well
yeah yeah they're really good at getting
the hairstyles that reflect the
characters very well yeah like it's
slick and cool the character won't be
slick literally everyone from like
cyberpunk Edge Runners as well yeah like
everyone looks so distinct uh but just
like Lucy's hair and [__]
man I remember first time seeing Lucy's
character design her hair her like yeah
everything I'm like damn I was like
trigger still got it man I just played
that boy scenes like Perfection
perfect that's why he's the ghost why is
the ghost
I love that trap it's so good [__]
love that
oh my God it's all right it's all right
I guess
we'll show you this trend of course like
it's it's this meme of just using the
Pokemon starters yeah yeah yeah using
certain react Clips uh to rate like you
know doing anything yeah and it's the
same thing
yeah yeah the Charlie screams oh yeah
anyway that was the final tangent we
went on yeah uh hopefully you guys
enjoyed this AI generated episode
um I was impressed with the topics yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah some of them we know
ourselves some of them were uh very on
brand for trash taste and and it brought
up a bunch of topics I'm surprised we it
took us this long to actually talk about
yeah yeah
very impressed yeah very important we
might do this again did you enjoy which
would you like to see another AI
generated episode like to see trash
taste being slowly overtaken by our AI
overlords let us know did you even know
this was AI
to Crusher